Okay. Guy Miasnik, thank you so much
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Very good, Michael.
Thank you for having me here.
Of course you're good.
Look at this view
that you're talking from.
Where are you now?
I am now from my home office.
This is covid time.
We are all shuttering in place.
Well, it's a beautiful
beautiful home office.
But the view,
the view is from Mount Rose in Tahoe.
And that's where I was two weeks ago,
climbing with my bike up, and so.
Climbing with your what?
Bike. Bike.
I didn't know you can climb with a bike.
With the motorcycle.
Yeah. When we a have mountains also,
but they're in Tahoe.
You basically walk up and you climb.
Work hard. Play hard.
Guy, we have so much to talk about
because, the most fascinating thing
that as you know,
and in preparation for this
I asked a simple question.
I want to talk about
the things you're passionate about.
And your different experiences.
And I listed like seven things
we could talk about, because you were
the chief strategy officer
of the BlackBerry.
And you sold the company
for $200 million to BlackBerry,
and HBS, and so on.
And you mentioned,
at the essence of it,
you're an entrepreneur.
And that is your true passion.
Beyond the combination
of all of these specific things.
Guy, what does it mean to you
that you are an entrepreneur?
And you've been an entrepreneur
for quite some time.
So, you pretty have some good
in your understanding
of what it means to you.
That's a great question, Michael.
So, entrepreneur is really at the essence.
It's in the heart.
It's about an impeccable desire
to create something that makes an impact.
It's about shaping it the way
you believe it should be shaped.
And it's really being having the passion
to work with dedicated
and brilliant people.
These are, for me, the three things
that really make or drive me,
and motivates me,
in the entrepreneurial world.
It's create something.
Make an impact, shape it
and work with amazing people.
And you get that.
And you get that
and you can make that happen
in this kind of the context.
When did you become an entrepreneur?
What was your turning point?
Was it after business school?
Before business school?
In high school.
Okay.
So, my first entrepreneurial venture
[--]
was actually, almost a non profit.
I was in high school in Kfar Saba.
And there was a boarding school over there
for very talented kids
that come from a bit
of a more difficult background.
And somehow I got connected
to the head of that boarding school.
And I was sort of as a kid
and as a high school guy.
I knew computers.
I was passionate about computers and said,
"Listen, I have some amazing,
talented kids in my boarding school."
"And what can you do?"
So, we sat down and I said,
"You know what?"
"We are going to create a computer class."
"Computer school
for afternoon activities for your kids."
And you did that.
When did you do that?
This was about six,
or about like latter part of 11th grade.
11th grade? Wow.
And I recruited a couple of my friends.
And we went out
and we built the curriculum.
And we figured out
that we have to purchase some computers
for computer [--]
from some people who donated the money
and we created for them a class
and taught it.
So, it was my first entrepreneur.
Now, it's not a business.
It's not a big startup.
But it was creating something
out of nothing.
I made an impact.
And I did it with some of my best friends.
So, that's entrepreneurship on day one.
That's high school
and then it just continues from there.
I love it. I'm taking so much inspiration.
I'm coming from
a pretty similar background.
I was, I think of myself
pretty entrepreneurial
back in high school.
Especially when it comes to
starting a robotics team.
Or convincing the administration
to have the BC calculus class
even though we don't have it.
And I think the most inspiring thing
is that, after all those years, and after
the incredible journeys you've had,
you still go back
to that high school experience.
Which, like you're saying,
it's not a startup, it's not a business.
But you created value out of thin air,
and that is entrepreneurship.
Give me in two words
this HBS experience.
You're at Harvard Business School,
one of the top places in the world
for entrepreneurship and business,
what are those two years like?
A life changing.
So,  I've been entrepreneur before.
I had this one company in Israel.
Successful, got acquired.
But it was small scale.
And the move to HBS into the US
open your eyes.
Opened my eyes as an Israeli.
I'm talking about '97, '98,
to a much broader world.
A much bigger way
of thinking about things.
And HBS does it for you.
It basically shifts your mind
from thinking
in your own network cubicle.
Okay, the last thing that I heard
was life changing.
You come in and you're no longer
in your own cubicle.
And then we froze.
That's actually made the point.
I mean, that's it.
We don't need to continue from that.
But really, the point was,
I actually had my own
little startup in Israel.
Which was a smaller scale startup.
And the move to the states,
the moved to HBS, specifically,
opened your eyes.
Allows us to really think about
much broader issues
and much bigger bigger bigger opportunity.
So, for me, that was a mega transition
coming from the small market of Israel
to the bigger world,
and to what I think about it
in a different way.
So, HBS was amazing.
And then besides that, it's people.
You get a chance to meet
some amazing amazing people.
Those two things.
First of all, I hear life changing,
but then I hear that it's both about,
understanding scale
and meeting incredible people.
What is it about these two years
that make you transition
from thinking small scale nice startup,
to, I'm going to go and sell a company
for $300 million
and become the CSO of BlackBerry.
Like, what is that transition?
I'm trying to understand.
Because obviously,
it's one of the dreams of mine
to come to get to a place like this.
But what is it?
So, first of all,
no one starts a startup that knows
that he's going to sell it for 300 million
and becomes CSO of any company.
So, it's really about
having the confidence
to make it different and to go.
Okay? Be ready to say,
I can do it despite
all of those crazy others
and crazy reasons,
and good reasons actually,
not to do anything.
And the fact that you have the confidence
and in some aspect, the crazy mindset
and the extremely optimistic mindset
to say, I'm going to do it, this exit.
And HBS helps that.
HBS actually, as a school
gives you the network,
gives you the confidence,
gives you the way to think about stuff.
And I'm not saying it's the only way.
There's many ways to get
to the kind of I'm on.
And I've been that before.
But it definitely gave me a great boost.
Now, the second thing,
my first investor, my second investor,
my business partner and my board members,
they're all HBS.
So, that helps.
Okay. So, that's the network side.
But to culminate this,
for anybody who doesn't get the chance
to go to  HBS,
or Stanford Business School,
summarize, what is the key takeaway
that resonated
throughout your journey there
that you think,
this is a lesson that really resonates
throughout this experience?
Got it. Okay. To really get that,
to speak a bit about the experience,
entrepreneurial experience
that I went through,
and it was actually somewhat unique
even for the Silicon Valley.
If you count from day one
to day exit, let's call it,
it was from 2000 to 2016 or 15,
so, it's about 15 or 16 years,
not a common path.
Wow.
And went to 9/11,
that well I should say,
from the .com bubble burst in 2000, 9/11,
and then later, the financial crisis.
So, three mega mega crisis
which caused changes, caused pivots
and still at the end resulted in actually
a very successful company.
But it wasn't without a scar
and it wasn't without tremendous
tremendous amount of work.
So, if there was one key lesson,
there's a few, but one key lesson is,
and that's something
you don't know necessarily at HBS.
[--]
many places in life is
if you're not in the game,
you can't win. Okay?
If you're not in the game,
you can't win.
So, you need to figure out
how do you stay in the game
despite everything.
Despite whatever is thrown at you,
you need to figure out
how to stay in the game.
And then you need to figure out
how to change and adapt
as the game and as the landscape change
so, you don't get stuck.
If you continue to be stuck
you would be outside.
But if you're in the game,
and if you're flexible enough
to adjust and pivot,
if you don't get panic
when the crisis are at you,
but actually you seize the opportunity
that they provide
and you're ready for the long term,
you'll get there.
I love it. Okay.
So, changing the landscapes.
You finished HBS.
Talked about, you move on
to create AtHoc, right?
AtHoc and ending up in BlackBerry.
Take me through this journey.
So, you start a company.
All of a sudden you're transitioning.
You're in security.
And you get to join this great company
that previously was a pioneer in mobile.
And you were just telling me that
that would be a lot of people
don't know is that,
there is a lot more to BlackBerry
than just mobile phones.
It's actually, it transitioned
into a software company.
And actually dealing with also,
a lot of automobiles, right?
So, the BlackBerry
is an amazing story by itself.
And we can probably speak
about this for a few hours.
It's exactly no there.
But it's a company that
was at its peak.
Was at the head of mobile
and was leading the world
leading mobile devices.
And frankly, missed the boat
when Apple came in with smartphones.
And as a result, collapsed.
And stayed in the field mainly,
because it had
its tremendous amount of money
but did not figure out about the people.
Until their current CEO came.
Which is a way before I joined
and decided,
Okay, let's pivot this company
to become a software business.
It is John Chen, right?
That's John Chen.
And John Chen did a great job
in really rescuing the business
because the rate it's going,
it's going outside.
A big part of what he did
it was acquisition.
He figured out that he needs
to bring in talent and assets
in order to make a transition
of this nature.
So, it's the technologies,
the customers, the people.
And that's why there was a big match
with what we brought in.
We were a company
that was dealing with communication,
with government contracts,
with the security, with finance,
financial services, etc,
all of the things that are actually
BlackBerry is looking for.
And that's how the merge came in.
And we basically were acquired and got in.
Now, from within, it's a different story.
It's a different story
because now, you're part of the team.
And I was in the executive team over there
trying to figure out
how to take this new vision,
which is not easy.
And transition this company
from a mobile device
with all of these assets that we acquired,
these assets, not a company
that I'm quite good with technologies
and a bunch of smaller companies
that were acquired a bit earlier on.
And get all of these entities together
to speak together
and really provide value.
And that was one of my task as a CSO,
is to figure out
and put some directioning on.
Now one of the things
that was fascinating is,
one of these assets
was a company called QNX.
Which was around secuity for cars.
And they provide software
that really provides that.
And in the world of security,
in the world of automated cars
and everything that we are seeing
in this market,
BlackBerry actually has a big play.
And another one of the key points
of the work that we've done at the time.
But still, it's a company in progress.
And BlackBerry's still needs to be proven.
To prove that it can take that next step.
Guy, these are these are things
that you really hear about
in university in case studies.
Companies that are coming.
Their market leaders.
And all of a sudden
they lose their footing.
And they have to figure out
how to either how to stay in the game.
And you got to play
the chief strategy officer
during that time of learning
how to stay in the game
and thinking about
how to make these acquisitions.
What are some of the challenges
that you're addressing here?
Are there different cultural challenges?
Or different adversities
that people don't know where we're headed?
Because people, I'm guessing,
are looking at you and saying,
"Hey, you're the chief strategy officer."
"What's our strategy?"
You're outlining what is the strategy
of BlackBerry to stay in the game?
So, it's actually quite fascinating
to that startup life
and turn around life,
and in Blackberry it was a turnaround,
are actually surprisingly similar.
And you will be thinking about
turning around a billion dollar business
and starting a young company
with zero funding is the same.
But there's a lot
of other similarities in it.
One, you need to figure out your story.
If you need to figure out your message.
And in a turnaround, it's a new message.
In the startup, It's a new message.
You need to keep focus.
It's not easy to keep focus.
Okay?
Even in a startup,
you can lose focus very quickly.
In a billion dollar business,
you can lose focus even faster.
Of course.
So, how do you craft your message.
How do you focus your business.
How do you get your technologies
and your people aligned.
The alignment of all the people,
all of the stakeholders around you.
In the startup, it's small.
In a billion dollar business,
it's many more.
Now, just for context
about how many people
are in the company around this time?
How many are we talking here?
5,000, give or take.
And it's a public company.
So, it's not just the employees.
It's the customers.
It's the partners.
And it's the investors.
And you're turning around the strategy
for a company of 5,000 employees.
It's not just about the company.
It's about maintaining alignment.
Now, the credit goes to John.
He's the CEO.
I'm not taking his credit in this respect.
But I get to talk
to the chief strategy officer now.
So, John, thank you very much.
But I'm learning from you at this moment.
So, you're representing
the executive team.
But that was a very fascinating process.
And again,
the similarities with the startup life
were fascinating.
And that's what the key message
in thinking about turnarounds
is exactly how to do that
and how to deal with such crisis changes.
I love it. Okay.
So, Guy, two successful endeavors.
An executive in a public company,
Harvard Business School.
You've probably achieved
every entrepreneur's dream.
Talk to me a little bit
about venture capital, Miasnik Ventures.
Why venture capital?
Why now?
What is your source?
Why now? Yeah.
First of all, it's not a venture capital.
Okay?
It's a different phase in my life now.
I've done three startups.
The business startups.
Not including the non-business startups.
And what I'm still fascinated by
is that early stage foundation
and incubations of businesses.
That's what drives me.
Because that's the time
where you can shape, you can direct,
you can really figure out
and create something
that is completely new.
So, that's what I do right now.
I really work
with very early stage entrepreneurs.
Sometimes, it could be a professor
that he has some ideas
and wants to figure out
how to commercialize it
to some class.
And other case could be
an executive that wants to get out
and figure out where to go.
Sometimes only an existing team
that may have some initial funding
and wants to figure out
how to take the next step.
And I joined them.
I joined them in some capacity.
Typically, it's a bit of an investment
and advisory board position.
But it's a very executive position.
Meaning, I spend a lot of time.
I work, I try to really make sure
that they don't make my mistakes.
Let them create their own mistakes
but don't make my mistakes
and learn from that experience.
And at the end, I'm looking for,
is number one, is amazing people.
That's for me, the number one criteria
in every one of these decisions
and endeavors.
And obviously,
it needs to be a fascinating market.
The field, you want to be in the field,
you better enjoy the field
[--]
I'm always looking for things
that have an impact.
And have some social impact.
And I've been working in public safety.
I've been working in security.
I've been working in healthcare,
education, it's areas
where you can actually feel
and sense the impact
of what you're creating.
And also sectors that attract
certain types of people.
And I'm not talking about
necessarily just the founders,
but the entire ecosystem around it.
Remember that when we, in our talk
which was at the end
the public safety company
and got about 200 people,
we had amazing guys.
We have people who are ex-militarily,
ex-firefighters, people who came
from emergency management of counties
People that were
really living the mission.
And that's the passion and the mission
is a very crucial part of this.
Very very cool.
So, you're saying
working with entrepreneurs.
Working with them
as almost joining their team.
But when we started the conversation,
the first thing you mentioned was that,
when you're an entrepreneur,
is you are guided by emotions
and this urge to do something
that doesn't exist.
A lot of people say
that entrepreneurs have to be crazy.
So, it must be frustrating sometimes
when you're working with entrepreneurs,
you've made the same mistakes
they're about to make.
You know they're going to make
this mistake.
But entrepreneurs are guided
by emotion sometimes.
And I'm sure that sometimes,
they don't listen.
Sometimes they need to make that mistake.
Is that frustrating to you?
Or do you say,
Okay. I'm going to let them
make this mistake?
So, you know what?
I have three kids.
One of them is now 21 years old.
He has his own startup.
Yeah.
And so, when you raise kids,
you go through the same thing.
You see what they do.
You try to give them
your best advice and wisdom.
And hopefully most of the time,
they'll listen.
Sometimes they don't listen.
Hopefully most of the time you're correct.
But sometimes you're not correct as well.
So, it's a matter of really the team
and the people that you work with.
And to find ones
that can have a mutual respect.
But also, remember something
really important.
At the end, it's their startup.
Okay? It's not you.
If you are joining, in this case, it's me.
If I'm joining and I'm supporting them.
Still supporting them
but they are the founders.
They are the entrepreneurs.
They are the guys that are in the trenches
and will go and make that happen.
So, we always have to remember that.
I love it. I love it.
And I'm learning so much
through our work together in J-Ventures.
And just, I think that your passion
for helping entrepreneurs
just shines through this.
And I look forward
to working together much more.
And I had a wonderful chat
with your son the other day.
And I was just so impressed
and so taken back
that he was really doing
incredible things.
And now I understand
the mentorship that he gets.
But Guy, before we leave,
I have to ask for three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Got it. Okay.
You give me a few minutes
heads up on this one.
But we were speaking throughout.
I didn't have too much time to think.
So, when I tell you
that you have 90 minutes to prepare,
it's actually a lie.
Because you have to answer me
for these 19 minutes.
So, I would say, one, is passion.
Passion in whatever you do.
And enjoy whatever you do.
Number two, is persistency.
I spoke about it. Just be there.
Be there and play the game.
Play the game and stay in the game.
And number three, it's family.
And family is obviously
your own immediate family.
But family is also the team
that you create you build in your startup.
And the ecosystem you build around it.
And if you treat them as a family,
it is the thing, they become your family.
And that's the perfect startup.
Guy, toda raba.
Thank you very very much.
Thank you for the time.
Thank you for the inspiration.
And then I'll see you around
in our monthly meetings.
Michael, thank you very much.
Take care.
Bye bye.